>> Chris: IT'S TIME FOR WANNA
CYBER?
KIDS LOVE TO USE THAT PHRASE.
IT'S CYBER MONDAY, GUYS, AND
SALES TODAY WERE AROUND THREE
BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE IT TURNS
OUT, PEOPLE LIKE SHOPPING WHILE
NOT WEARING PANTS!
AlTHOUGH THEY ALSO COULD HAVE
GONE TO WALMART FOR THAT.
ACCORDING TO THIS PHOTO.
>> GOOD FOR HIM.
WHY NOT.
>> I LIKE.
THAT.
>> Chris: THIS GUY IS TRYING
SMUGGLE
A PACK OF FUN-SIZE ROLOS IN HIS
SHORTS.
COMEDIANS, IT DOESN'T TAKE A
CYBER GENIUS TO SEE THAT ONLINE
DEALS ARE NOT CREATED EQUAL, SO
GIVE ME AS MANY BAD CYBER MONDAY
DEALS AS YOU CAN.
BEGIN.
>> FREE GUN RECENTLY FIRED.
NO QUESTIONS ASKED,
>> Chris: MICHELLE.
>> FREE LAKERS TICKETS.
Chris: BRENT.
>> BYE ONE WNBA TICKET GET ALL
OF THE WNBA TICKETS FREE.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: RICK.
>> BUY A PAIR OF NIKE HE'S AND
GET THE SECOND AT FULL PRICE.
>> Chris: MICHELLE.
>> FREE SENSE OF ENTITLEMENT
WITH EVERY JUSTIN BIEBER ALBUM
SOLD.
Chris: BRENT.
FREE TASING AT PARTICIPATING
FLORIDA POLICE STATIONS.